te rappelle qu'on avait chanté ensemble
elle me contrôle exactement
c'est ça je vous le dis et jeans serré
c'est fini
tout ça alors
tu as fait le tour en fait tu as fait le
tour le symptôme de carrière maintenant
c'est pas un qui franchement
et je voudrais dire et Max et pourquoi
il a fait 20 ans de carrière il a une
qualité que je n'ai pas l'humilité
non mais c'est rigoler c'est le mec le
plus humble que je connaisse donc c'est
vrai et puis c'est le seul gars je le
redis à chaque fois c'est le seul gars
tu peux manger des crêpes à 3h du matin
lui il prendra toujours une bouteille
d'eau avec un petit truc avec du quinoa
un truc comme ça c'est pour ça qu'il est
toujours frais ça va mon frère je suis
content de te voir et est-ce que tu veux
pas me faire un kiff je viens d'avoir
l'idée parce que tu as vu qu'il y a
Lionel team qui est là je te rappelle de
lui ou pas
les mecs vous voulez pas qu'on fasse je
crois en monétaire
bien sûr attends vas-y vas-y ramène toi
on ne connaît pas
ça c'est historique ça c'est historique
pour les 20 ans c'est historiques
[Applaudissements]
pas je la connais frères
c'est moi qui commence c'est toi qui
commande c'est qui qui fait aussi
ne me demande pas d'où je viens les
cicatrices sur mon chemin tes lieux ça
peut changer
au fond
on se fait mal quand on casse des liens
tu sais ça me touche tout sympa mais
qu'est-ce que ça peut changer
au fond
[Musique]
on va tous quelque part sur le chemin de
notre mort
mais jamais
on se rend pourquoi j'ai changé les
couleurs du noir
je
crois mon étoile elle est le point de
départ le matin de toutes les histoires
Matt Pokora Lionel
et ça ça
[Applaudissements]
c'est fort et ça c'est fort c'est très
fort
tu as travaillé tu as bossé